he gets a wide open look I mean that  that's a horse to look Michael Russo  Nations  [Applause]  Green what 14th Street on the road  leading to the one you kept looking  Dublin Desai school either got  what 14th Street on the road you see it  right here yeah you got a double teaming  now draw get four three want a shot  fights wrong  but an important shot this time sighs  Ron Jane with  Ranjan cursor just sits at 15 get it  back  let him take them yourself didn't tear  drop my Brogdon Ava's time leave mr.  Russo take guard LeBron is allowed to  feed on the two-man game  solid screen for sometimes he gets his  blinked  that's a teardrop but broadly series  tied with the Lakers at 102  he's got that rim to protect and number  seven has put the Pacers in front in  India  [Music]  Rondo  from Rwanda Cocula and the Pacers happy  the Lakers  [Applause]